[Music]
hello there free to play video games
have the uncanny ability to be either
great or a total waste of time so every
six months I tell you about the games
with the most potential and a few that
are so unique they deserve a little
attention some of these games will be
dropping this summer While others will
be here in 2024. please leave a comment
of your top three so I can plan the
content around them thank you kindly
here's 18 new free-to-play games coming
soon first a quirky little game coming
this year is metabol an action sport
game set on a basketball court while
players ride on hoverboards with
definite inspiration from rocket league
metabol is a fast-paced action-packed
trick-filled PVP contest currencies play
a part in progression as ranking Point
unlock equipment and a more standard
shop is here for Cosmetics scheduled for
release in the second half of 2023
metabol will be totally free to play
multi-platform on Playstation Xbox and
PC with players in charge of how
competitive they want to be as a rider
competing in merciless metabol League
games will this have the appeal of
Rocket League or the pulling power of
roller Champions find out later this
year a highly anticipated free game for
a few years now is Arc Raiders and it
has finally reached public testing in a
closed Alpha ark raiders is a third
person extraction shooter set around
pvpve meaning we'll be going up against
Ai and other real players in a brutal
world before somehow getting out alive
confirmed for both PC and consoles
arcaders was to release in 2022 before
realigning to 23 but if I'm completely
honest I think it's more realistic to
say this is coming next year 2024. I'll
keep you updated but just look at it
this could be something special indeed
my hero Ultra Rumble is a 24 player
Battle Royale game in which eight teams
of three players fight to be the last
one surviving recently a Revival system
is confirmed and plus Ultras have been
showcased and even more characters have
been added to the roster too battle
royale's may be becoming a less
desirable genre these days but Ultra
Rumble attempts to do something
different with it open testing was
hugely successful and the release window
is now here it's coming this year in
fall but which month of autumn that is I
don't know place your bets now September
October or November a game with a fixed
release date now is Disney's speedstorm
releasing on all platforms on September
28th speedstorm is an arcade racer in
the Mario Kart mold that lets you race
with your favorite Disney and Pixar
characters as they jump behind the wheel
of some weird and wonderful Vehicles
each with unique power-ups and abilities
speed storm as I'm saying this is in
paid Early Access but as of September
28th it's a free-for-all on Playstation
Xbox PC and switch gets one too nice one
a free to play game I'm looking forward
to comes from the team that brought us
Warframe whenever I bring up Warframe
people either love it or absolutely hate
it it's a very polarizing game indeed so
frame is shrouded in mystery right now
with only small glimpses of this free to
play Fantasy open world and its
mechanics we do know that the sister
game sets itself more on medieval
fantasy compared to the sci-fi fantasy
of Warframe so it looks more like Elden
ring in Aesthetics we will find out more
about Soul frame on August 26th at 10
o'con so realistically this is probably
the game furthest away to release on
this list my guess would be 2025 but I'd
love to be wrong one thing I feel is
guaranteeable as this is a digital
extremes game it's almost certain that
the end game will be all about looking
as good as possible getting the best
gear and showing off to everyone who
doesn't have it there are two
free-to-play football games releasing
this year the one played with a foot on
a ball and the one played with hands on
an egg the American football game is
maximum football a simulation game as
head coach we are in charge of leading
the team to Victory making all the
decisions behind the scenes from
drafting your roster to calling each
play with tons of in-depth customization
to get Austin and skill trees to master
maximum football could be a great change
of pace maximum football releases on PC
and console in Autumn this year the
association football game is UFL a
totally free to play competitor to FIFA
at least they hope it to be the basic
premise is simple choose a team and take
control of them on the pitch changing
tactics to get the best out of each
player and ultimately running around on
the pitch like a madman after scoring a
goal big names like Ronaldo debrun
Lukaku are involved in this project so
it should have some sway when it finally
releases later in 2023 on PC PlayStation
and Xbox have you seen the first
descendant a third person looter shooter
it's an RPG that feels like a third
person style of Destiny kind of outing
look they even have a large golf ball in
the sky boss fights look great and
selectable characters seem unique and
interesting these distinctive characters
will have unique play Styles built for
different scenarios games like Anthem
have made people kinda skeptical of
creating these games but will you be
fighting off Invaders with your friends
on a Tuesday night after school and work
the first descendant is currently in
open testing and could release in late
2023 but my complete random guess is May
2024. next we have the division
Heartland a free-to-play survival
shooter set in the divisions universe
but away from the main storyline the
main Hook is that the cumbersome
elements of the mainline series have
been streamlined to make Heartland as
approachable as possible we play as a
division agent protecting Silver Creek
from both AI enemies and other players
the story takes place after the green
poison has hit the world and looks at
how small towns adapted to survive the
division Heartland drops on Playstation
Xbox and PC later this year speaking of
the PVP and PVE hybrid games check out
synced a futuristic Cooperative shooter
in a world overrun by Nanos which have
Rogue technology that has brought
civilization to its demise we are
deployed with our squad or alone to
fight the AI plague We sync up with one
of four character classes Crusher
Guardian Seer and suppressor each with
the usual different play Styles
strengths and weaknesses trailers have
spoken about outmaneuvering opponents
and not solely relying on gunfire so
synced could have more depth than it
first seems synced will be on
Playstation Xbox and PC later this year
another game extremely similar to this
is shatter line yet this one is in first
person rather than third person set in
the near future where Humanity faces a
threat of cosmic proportions players
take on the role of the immunes bearers
of an extremely rare genetic combination
that allows their bodies to resist this
alien plague whether you prefer player
versus environment or player versus
player chataline has plenty of both to
offer I have a fear shatter line may get
lost among all the other games releasing
a game many players are talking about is
the finals a combat centered TV game
show that's why a commentator can be
heard when playing always hyping up your
actions take to the set and fight
alongside teammates in Virtual Arenas
that are made to be altered with amazing
destruction it's like a game of
Battlefield teams of three complete
objectives such as opening a vault and
escaping with the money while constantly
fighting off other players the best
comparison a player has made to me was
Battlefield Bad Company mixed with
OverWatch that does sound quite
interesting to me the finals is due to
release in 2023 but I'm not very
confident the console version will be
ready in time this year as always I hope
to be wrong how about a massively
multiplayer online role-playing game
MMORPGs are making a comeback well MMO
lights like this one wayfinder is a game
which has the backing of PlayStation
behind it releasing on PS5 and PC in
summer this year so sometime before
September 23rd a character-based action
RPG with each character owning different
abilities the art style is super vibrant
as we'll be exploring dungeons crafting
our armor and weapons adding augments
and surviving a hostile World which is
overrun by something called the Gloom
something I valued when I heard it was
the confirmation that all characters are
fully voice acted I needed that I don't
like reading one thing I think we should
be aware of is that way finder is a
free-to-play game yet will release in
Early Access which has become a way to
ask players to pay to be there from day
one I may be jumping to conclusions and
my inner cynic is exposed but either way
I'll be sure to let you know when it
truly is free to play but for what it's
worth I think it looks very good another
MMO is ashfall a much more gritty
version of this genre inspired by The
Fallout series with a world filled with
hidden vaults to find the game promises
quite a lot with Dynamic weather
authentic gun damage and recoil patterns
characters that change and mutate over
time the premise is set in the
post-apocalypse as AI Rises up and we
must find the core of creation to end
this living nightmare the genuine
gameplay footage looks very rough at
this moment in time which lines up
perfectly with the release date this is
expected in September 2024. another
upcoming MMORPG has been delayed but
it's also out now strange okay blue
protocol the Japanese version is live
yet the Western release has now been
postponed to 2024. this online RPG may
look like gentian impact but we're told
the combat has way more depth than
genjin and to fully obtain the potential
of Your Arsenal skills will take time
supported by Deep customization from
facial hair to the color of your Mount
individuality is definitely here in blue
protocol five class types have been
showcased including a blade Warden a
spell Weaver and a dual wielding twin
Striker choosing an RPG to main these
days is getting quite hard to end here's
a bunch of games you probably already
know about but are due to drop any day
now with free to play updates X defiant
ubisoft's Call of Duty competitor is
expected to fully release over summer
this year on Playstation Xbox and PC
whereas the game which blends The Sims
and Animal Crossing with Disney
franchises dreamlike Valley finds itself
in the Early Access limbo we talked
about earlier it's technically a free to
play game out now yet it's behind a
paywall that will change this year when
the community simulator based in the
Disney Universe will become available to
all free for all oh and naraka blade
point is finally out of Xbox exclusivity
and becomes a totally free to play melee
Battle Royale releasing very soon July
13th on Playstation Xbox and PC 60
players are thrown onto an island to do
battle and be the last surviving if
Warzone and fortnite have become a
little monotonous but Battle Royale is
still your jam naraka blade Point may be
the game for you and then that brings us
to my much beloved multiverses this game
has been through a lot it's been
released in Early Access and now it's
been taken completely offline to be
re-released in 2024. Multiverse is the
platform fighter was great but it
struggled to engage players for long
periods of time and I really hope they
fixed that issue so that's 18 free games
please let me know which ones you're
into and I'll add them to my watch list
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been an
absolute pleasure I'll see you next time